hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and i have another
hardware review for you guys courtesy of
the kind folks at solo laptop cases and
you can obviously check out their link
in the description of this video and you
can also follow them on twitter at
twitter.com solo laptop cases uh for
like uh many updates and little promo
codes and stuff like that
so uh let's just get into this uh full
review video this is going to be of
their 17-inch laptop messenger bag
since i do have a 17-inch laptop i
figured i would show you guys uh other
people out there who have a 17-inch
laptop who actually do go mobile with
theirs uh what this
this bag is like
i actually traveled with it once earlier
about a week and a half ago and i
actually traveled with it yesterday so i
do have a pretty good experience with
this bag and what it's like so i
basically open it on the front right
here with this little buckle
and uh
opening it up right in the front here is
a mini pocket mini pocket mini pocket
and then a little uh transparent pocket
that you can put like an id in you could
put a uh just a little identification
just to let people know that's yours
um so two pen pockets on either side and
a couple small pockets that's just the
the little uh
the little mini compartments no one
really uses those pockets i found that i
didn't use them or i didn't actually
have a long enough trip to use those but
i'm sure they come in handy for some
people
so let's just go ahead and open this up
this is where the main this is where the
good part is this is what i what i
really like about it you unzip it
completely
and we have like a full-on uh organizer
kind of thing in here there's a pocket
these two pockets down here
one and two are where i put my charger
so i have the two uh different parts of
the charger in these two i didn't really
put anything in here but this is the
main part where i put the charger then
you pull this divider back and have a
whole organizer full of stuff cell phone
uh
cell phone charger all these different
things can be put in those compartments
right there
as we move on here this is actually i
left my cooler in here from traveling
yesterday but i have my mini uh my
little portable laptop cooler that i put
in that compartment so let me just zip
this up
so yeah in here i have uh the laptop
goes in this compartment which is
actually velcro and you can just pretty
much slide it in there it's a pretty uh
pretty good size uh 17 inch laptop will
fit in there quite nicely
and then in this other part you can put
like a mini laptop cooler which is
actually what i used uh to put in there
so the laptop cooler is in there you
secure your laptop just like that and
close it up
so yeah it is a it is a good size and
the way it holds your stuff is really
secure uh the way it's zippered and
everything so it's really uh it's really
a handy thing to have if you're gonna go
mobile so as i close this up here uh you
may have noticed in the unboxing video
if you watched closely there was
actually a secret hidden compartment
annotation that i added to the video
uh so if you didn't already watch the
unboxing you can check that out if i
flip this over here
yes there are more pockets
one is a zipper that actually goes up
into the laptop we could just even put
like a notebook in there or a piece of
paper papers in there and also there's
another one going down into the bottom
of the laptop so one coming up and one
going down so that's pretty cool you can
just stick a few papers in there work it
out at a meeting or something um
yeah that's pretty much it for you guys
so uh that is the solo 17 inch laptop
messenger bag
uh from solo laptop cases if you do want
to go check this out the link to this
will be in the description of this video
so you guys can check out the laptop
there the laptop case there too anyway
thanks to solo for sending this out to
me i hope to get to you guys with more
great product reviews and uh thanks for
watching this video guys and i hope you
stay tuned for more if you subscribed
thank you very much and uh that's
basically it so have a nice night peace